hallo leute ich sie höre mein wanne und
ja ich befinde mich in meiner neuen
küche
diese küche ist so schön und das erste
mal in der geschichte von max besitze
ich eine arbeitsfläche mein gott trassen
zum video habe ich mir ein t shirt
geholt die ganze bibliothek werden jetzt
wahrscheinlich aus grafs zu weiß gerade
nicht wo ich das bestellte wir müssen
einfach beliebten so eingeben dann
werdet ihr das schon finden fashion show
das sind b388 ersten sabrina einzelnen
winds wir reiten gestimmt das rezept von
frau matthäus butterkuchen steht auf der
offiziellen bibi und tina seite deswegen
musste ich nicht viel recherchiert und
wenn ich selber über das ausgedacht
hätte hätten wieder 100 leute gemerkt
habe gesagt haben
und alles was wir für frau machens
butter tuch brauchen ist ein rückblick
man kann die höhe man kann verstehen für
praktisch zur parade 50 gramm medien mai
kommen hier backpulver höher bei 6 cache
war marie ist so cool jede menge poker
wir brauchen auch noch vanillezucker hex
hex mensch ist absolut heute nicht mit
ein bisschen schwieriger wir brauchen
eier und dafür habe ich uns einen vogel
besorgt hallo du lieben kannst du bitte
ergeben
was ist denn das hinter deinem pro ist
es etwa 1 1
wir brauchen aber 3
schon viel besser drei eier dahin lieber
vogel du kannst jetzt wieder wegfliegen
und schlagsahne und obendrauf für den
butterkuchen brauchen wir 125 grad
mutter von 25 grad kann
125 g zucker blättchen und last but not
least drei esslöffel ich brauche meine
zauberstab stäbchen und jetzt schauen
wir uns um die geräte her eine schüssel
warum braucht natürlich eine vage ene
mene frage ich brauche jetzt nur vage
exakt france mein brief nach hama jetzt
wirklich muss mein brief und ein
handrührgerät phänomene blumenbeet ich
brauche noch ein handrührgerät sex
unverpackt ja und was jetzt kannst dir
das absolut keine magie es gibt ihn aber
auch eigentlich gar nicht um die man ihn
oder es ist eher so diese sphäre der
beste freundin hat bibi und tina geliebt
jetzt auch glaube ich jeder kassette
ich war da eher sowie blocksberg fan und
sie so bettina
was müssen wir machen barack obama
das ist ja der einfachste kuchen der
welt willkommen in die schüssel und 150
gramm zucker haus das wie zucker eine
tüte frisches koks fresh aus kolumbien
was war dann allerdings tag bei diesem
ganzen universum von der caracol um die
super auf alle sagen
einer kolumne brille auf vanillezucker
und dann verlor ich die trockenen
zutaten miteinander trockene zutaten
was passiert jetzt seit wann ist
eigentlich auch ein bisschen magisch
weil wenn du sahne ist dann willst du
magisch ein bisschen breit hat es auch
ein bisschen zauber gott 3 1 wollte ich
eigentlich noch ein kameramann der so
neben mir steht und nicht so film nichts
mit all den teig das video einfach
nennen so macht ihren eigenen schleim
stimmt das erinnert mich in dieses
schlanke system unser backblech müssen
wir jetzt ein fed ließ einen riegel
butter oder ist schön das ganze bald
gleich einen fetten abstrakte kommt man
zum teig naschen und jetzt kommt der
muttertag
was die schlüssel nicht fallen das wäre
ziemlich muss jetzt bald 28 grad ober
unterhitze in den augen und wer
schlaffer hat den ofen vorgehaltene
meine biber wir sehen uns gleich wieder
hexel 114 minuten im backofen und in der
zeit müssen wir das topping macht und
dafür brauchen wir 125 gramm wurde mit
müssen jetzt schmerzen monaten dann
zucker oder mandel actionreihe 400
karmann will wo das sind genau 100 gramm
drill nun günstig darauf verlasse ich
mich 125 gramm zucker
und jetzt haben doch drei ärzte für mich
dazu 12
jetzt höre ich meine masse in der jsa
vorschläge was heute - ich bin da ein
bisschen durch wind ich glaube es liegt
an der neuen küche dass ich hier noch
nie gedreht hat so ist jetzt unsere
zucker mandl mischung da in die pfanne
aber das riecht so gut die mandeln
zucker futtermischung sind so lange rum
prozent ist der ganze zurück geschmolzen
ist und gleich sollte auch schon der
kugel raus ich habe ja die uhr geschaut
verdammt ich wusste doch dass ich
irgendwas vergessen nein jetzt ist die
große frage wie kriege ich den kampf
doch ich hatte es nämlich heiße sachen
anzufassen jungs geschafft für mich
häufig wortwörtlich und die masse kommt
jetzt auch den kuchen
man wird nicht so ist es also wenn man
nach rezept kauft dann passt's rau ich
will mich an dieser stelle nochmal für
mein letztes match max entschuldigen ich
weiß es war so dumm dass in so ein
großes gefäß zu machen
ihr müsst nur kurz meine sicht verstehen
ich wollte das so nah wie möglich
hinkriegen und als ich dieses gefäß
gefunden hat darf sich so nur das ist
hier genauso profi gehen und habe nicht
darüber nachgedacht das ja bedeutet dass
ich auch viel mehr produkte nutzen muss
offizielle entschuldigung hier von
meiner seite wird absolutely amazing ja
und jetzt schauen wir auf die uhr bevor
wir das reinpacken es ist genau 37 11 57
womit sie das haus also zehn minuten
muss der sommerberg wenn ihr ihn zurück
in den ofen bekommt eine ewigkeit der
frau martins butterkuchen und höre man
auf den kosten die zocker mandl
mischungen hart geworden
auf der website sagen sie dass man den
kuchen anbieten sollen spontan gäste zu
kaffee um kommt deswegen machen wir so
ein café
borna kathy baker
wir stellen uns natürlich wieder der
allerwichtigsten frage wie schmeckt frau
massives butterkuchen auf www und
schiene wert ist so fluffig okay
der ist so lecker und für euch geht
natürlich wie immer wenn euch die folge
sein hat dann gibt es einen daumen nach
oben und aktiviert die glocke und keines
meiner neuen videos zu verpassen ich
wünsche euch eine hohe weihnachtszeit
mit ganz viel videos formal wanne
schaltet jeden tag ein
denn es kommt jeden tag ein video
hoffentlich möchte also wenn die
weiteren vorschläge aus film und serien
habt immer schön runter die kommentare
damit ich freue mich jedes mal ein ast
ab